all right this is a candy crush soda
saga demonstration on how to make fish
fish changed a little bit from the
original candy crush saga into candy
crush soda saga so now you can make them
by making a match of four candies in the
square so like here we have these three
we can bring the other balloon in and
get a fish the same thing here yellow
ones we have one more we can bring down
so the fish they they'll eat the ice or
the leet chocolate on chocolate boards
as well when you match two of them
together you can see they turn into
three and they'll eat three squares and
let's see if we can mix one together
with the striped here when you mix them
with the striped candy they they make
one stripe they take the place of one
strike whenever they eat whatever square
they're gonna eat so they'll similar in
one way or the other it doesn't matter
what which one you combine it with this
sort of random as far as as which one
comes together and you can match them
with the color bomb as well and this is
a really cool one especially on boards
like this that it's gonna turn all the
green candies on the board into fish so
you can do that and you can also match
it with the wrapped candy and when you
match with the wrapped candy it's gonna
it's gonna take out one of these ones
that's over top of a piece of chocolate
or in this case a piece of ice or
whatever and then it's gonna explode and
it'll take out all the squares and
vicinity so I'm trying to think if I can
get both on here I'm just gonna go ahead
and show you how the only color bomb
work because that's probably the coolest
one like I said this will eat all of
those tiles and finish the board off for
me so you can see that fish are a pretty
pretty effective special candy now they
work a lot different than they did
before so read our guide and you'll
you'll know all about them and how to
use them to get past some of the tougher
levels all right make sure if you have
any questions you comment and like the
video if you found that helpful thanks